I'm not sure it's what I should be best
known for but I'm best known for his
being one of the first to really say
that the Bush administration was not to
be trusted
so I was the first certainly the first
major newspaper or op-ed type writer to
to say that because I said it even
before the even before the 2000 election
was held so I can go back and point you
to columns from from the summer of 2000
that I think foreshadow at least
foreshadowed of the way most people now
think about the Bush administration
before there even was a Bush
administration I knew some things that
most journalists don't like arithmetic
and so I was looking at the policy
proposals and I just said they're lying
there they're they're not being honest
about what it is they're proposing and
that was a pretty good guide to me it
seemed to me that was that was much
better evidence than whether Bush seemed
like a guy that you wanted to have a
beer with
Social Security which was basically
counting the same couple of trillion
dollars twice he was saying we can have
it available to pay benefits but we can
also invest it and you'll get lots of
money out of it and it didn't that
didn't make sense taxes he was claiming
that his tax cuts favored the middle
class and you could do the math they
didn't they were very much tilted
towards the top and and there were a
bunch of other things smaller things but
just the the clear dishonesty about what
was actually in his own policy proposals
and being the kind of guy I am if you're
lying about the numbers that to me is
you know the it's not really the worst
offense but it's the clearest sign that
you're not a man you should be published